there's nothing that beats passion
nothing because what passion does is
create energy
what energy creates is a lot of output
in a short period of time
you got your prospective
[Music]
[Laughter]
good morning how are you guys I'm an
entrepreneur I run a 900 person
advertising and publishing agency that
is global based in the u.s. in the world
where people are trying to eliminate
adversity and we all have to be happy it
actually ends up that everybody's upset
because in real life every day there's
something that brings adversity and so
I'm with you I think 8th place trophies
and and you know being your PR agent on
social media is leading to depression
and anxiety and and mental health issues
and I'm proud that I talk about eating
crow and crap and you know work you know
I still you know love the fact that I
fly 30 hours to Australia and get right
on stage and speak and to me the hustle
and the grime and the process is the
payoff not not the financial or things
you buy with it and I think
unfortunately 99 percent are confused
thank you guys so much I'm so so humbled
to be on the show thanks guys
hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk how are you I
really appreciate that thanks for having
me on well I think what's great about
being an entrepreneur for me is that I
have nobody to answer to right I have a
lot of empathy for you like if you work
in radio stations things that nature the
truth is you have to bite your tongue
even with my company vaynermedia where
we have clients the reality is there are
times where I'm gonna bite my tongue
because the stakes are high but god it
is such a better life to actually speak
your truth and and especially if it
comes with good intent and kindness I
think the thing that's worked for me is
even though some of my content may seem
like I'm giving tough medicine it's
coming from a place where I'm desperate
for that person to be happy or more
successful uh words of advice go to a
retirement home and spend eight hours
with ten people that are in their 90's
and deeply consume the regret in their
eyes for all the things they didn't do
it will scare you straight into taking
action thank you guys have a great day
just to do two radio shows in Australia
really awesome there were some good
clips in there d-roc Q&A is when I come
out with my best stuff and now we're on
our way to Brisbane this trip has been
going amazing obviously super focused on
the Matchbox cars and the pins in trash
talk but also producing some incredible
content and getting some really good
time with the rock because we haven't
had it so that's been a very nice take a
stage in Brisbane really feeling it felt
really great and and so final carry over
that energy there great content day
tomorrow but I'm super early we've got a
New Zealand destroy some Kiwi faces got
a plane
connected Hawaii land go so my Energy's
up nice winds at Vayner media some
exciting stuff that you'll be hearing
about in the future so that's exciting
the vibes feel good
Jamaican bobsled pin is at $36 one pin
save one bit $36 in it I know but I'm
still like marveling in the excitement
of it oh snuffleupagus got a bit got a
bit bang woo the adidas went up to 14
just 1250 let me check thank you so much
and so for me accountability is the
greatest and most interesting thing I'm
fascinated by people's ability to dwell
and complain it's an unbelievably
interesting just so everybody
understands the only people listening
you dwell and complain are other [ __ ]
losers what I'm trying to accomplish
here this afternoon is to put pressure
on the truth if we are not striving for
happiness then we're not playing people
are amassing products and goods that
mean nothing people are trying to amass
status in front of others that means
nothing this is one humongous game of
self-awareness I desperately ask you if
you're motivated to not necessarily just
figure out how to run LinkedIn ads
against a white paper for your b2b
financial service business or had a DM a
hundred influencers every day of the
week and ask them to post a picture with
your product and ask them how much they
want then negotiate with them like it's
a garage sale and then see if it
actually works I need you to understand
what's happening out here and what's
happening out here is this is the
greatest era of abundance if you know if
you actually look at somebody else's
success and you're angry about it
because you've been tricked into
thinking that comes out of your success
you do not understand life I put out my
content for free because your attention
is more than enough I don't need to sell
you and
thing else because your attention is far
more valuable to me than your money you
get attention by putting out good [ __ ]
dude how many people here want to grow
their profiles but have never replied to
a comment of somebody that's left a
comment
you haven't jumped in and said thank you
or reply to their question I looked at a
bunch of you I looked at a bunch of you
I saw the hashtags for these [ __ ]
questions right the [ __ ] asha
askgaryvee Bri I looked and when I
looked at all your accounts 99% of you
do not reply to people's questions in
your Instagram portfolios while all you
give a [ __ ] about is growing your
Instagram portfolios how did I get here
from 2007 to 2011 I went to sleep at 4
o'clock in the morning every day every
day because I did not go to sleep until
I replied to every tweet I had and I was
running a wine business for 11 hours so
I didn't have time to do it during the
day
this isn't luck [ __ ] Johnny who's named
Johnny here
this is Anna luck [ __ ] Johnny this is
[ __ ] putting in the work
I'm just employing you to use today this
afternoon this talk to be the starting
point and that starting point an
opportunity is getting a clear mind so
it's super quiet and are putting out
your [ __ ] truth put out your content
what do you know what are you living
through if you're just starting out
document your journey of trying to
figure it out
speak your [ __ ] truth speak it loud
speak it often because you will regret
not squeezing this era live your life I
love you thank you thank you
[Music]
how many people are dis dinner how many
at this dinner hello hello
how are you if you look around this was
this really fun there's a lot of
businesses here that are b2b
you know we started with a very b2c very
trendy sexy business but the majority of
the businesses here quite b2b and what
but but the reality is is that what's
amazing about boring b2b businesses and
vaynermedia and what we do is we to be
it's not you know might be a little more
creative but is that you know who you're
targeting so thank you so I think that
um one of the things to talk about is I
actually think you could be you could a
lot of you looking around could
remarkably change the outcome of your
business through Facebook and LinkedIn
and podcasting and be outrageously
boring the reason I always have the
answer people ask me that I'm like cuz I
reverse engineer who the decision maker
is and then I ask enough questions to
figure out what brings them value I mean
a government official is trying to get
reelected or trying to build equity with
the person that they think is gonna get
reelected
everybody's got it's like I love Star
Wars because that for you know there's
this thing called the Death Star it
destroys everything yet if you just ride
a plane very carefully through a very
narrow place and drop a little thing on
this one little thing the whole thing
breaks that like and it always stuck
with me like everything's reverse
engineer able if you actually understand
who the decision-makers are and then
what do they need I'm a high growth
entrepreneur because I don't value
short-term economics so step number one
the biggest reason that I've been able
to build big businesses is there's not a
lot of 29 year old guys or gals that
spend 18 hours a day building a business
and are okay with taking home sixty
three thousand dollars while giving up
their entire 20s most people the reverse
they make money and they take it out of
the business to buy themselves things I
value my business over myself so one I
put all the money back in number two I'm
an innovator
so what innovators I'm a very good
salesman too even though I talk about
branding so I'm good enough to stay
alive while my thing that's gonna really
grow me grows so I'm selling social
media in two thousand nine ten eleven
twelve just enough to stay alive but
then in fourteen when it becomes real
I'm the guy and it all comes you know
it's a daily game like what was
yesterday I mean I can't wait to you
know I say so lately a lot with the Iraq
I was like I wish I was filming myself
back in the day cuz I would talk about
Direct Mail and other things and now I
[ __ ] on outdoor media I used to run
billboards all over New Jersey you know
there's gonna be a day where I'm gonna
make content that's gonna be like why
are you doing Instagram that's stupid
you know and that's gonna be fun because
then there will be a full cycle of
content to reference this era so I can
show people I'm not about social media
I'm about attention I think they were
starting to understand it once I started
getting excited about voice that's one
for be like okay this is a little bit
different than just he loves social
media know I've run an email I have an
email but I think email is an effective
way to still sell I really do um just
not as effective as it was 15 years ago
do everything and then allocate energy
and resources based on the reality of
everything so smoke signals is now zero
right but I'll still buy outdoor
billboards if because in Jersey and I
don't a spark it like a billboard that's
$20,000 a month if they don't have it
sold with a day to go could be 2,000 and
then I'm like well for a month mm okay
you understand and to me it's about is
attention overpriced for underpriced
one thing I really don't love about
being one of the poster childs of all
this is I'm such a high-energy
extroverted personality that it tricks
people into thinking that's what you
need to be but it's not you need to know
your craft you could be mundane and
boring if you know if you're doing b2b
and there's 37 people that are your
target and they just want the
information they just want the [ __ ]
information plus you don't have to make
video you can do audio you can write you
can make a PowerPoint and post it on
LinkedIn the other biggest thing that a
lot of you won't do that you need to
think about is give away your best
information for free it's very
counterintuitive why would they hire me
is it I know you want to transition but
like what if you why would they hire me
if I'm going to be an account if I teach
them how to do it because context
context is the value it's why this is
valuable like you can watch all my
content then the stage will be a little
more context and this is gonna be real
[ __ ] context and literally for you
like I know I've answered Pratt like you
know I've answered real stuff and I can
see like whoa okay like yo [ __ ] and
there'd be got like it's really valuable
when you can like um it's not like you
know getting to the insight unlocking
the change of perspective is everything
there's nothing that beats passion
not because what passion does is create
energy
what energy creaks is a lot of output in
a short period of time
[Music]
[Applause]
just like crippling you have to figure
out if it's insecurity that you like put
up a facade
and you don't want to actually go on the
field and prove it or is it just like
indecisiveness which is already a tell
that you might struggle running a
business so you just have to pick one
and go period get into the practice of
it it's really funny because I'm
obviously extremely extroverted and but
so many of the people I most admire some
of the best partners that ever have
employees executors you know are
unbelievably introverted as a matter
fact so many of the kids that I saw win
in Silicon Valley as we know because
they came really truly from tech nerd
culture were outrageously introverted I
think just not dwelling on the fact that
you're not extroverted in what is now a
Mimi personal brand post everything on
social media world I actually think it's
an advantage so for me like leveraging
the talent is very easy it's all down to
execution let me promise you something
for all my videos and cursing and
charisma and energy if I didn't actually
succeed in my executions
I wouldn't mean [ __ ] the biggest issue
right now in society is that somehow
we've craved this narrative that 18 or
22 or 30 year olds need to have their
[ __ ] figured out most 57 year olds don't
have their [ __ ] figured out and so the
pressure that you have to figure it out
is ludicrous of course you don't know
what your passion is you haven't even
[ __ ] lived yet so my biggest advice
is take advantage of this vacation right
navigate through it so they don't kick
you out and take as many weird courses
go to as many weird things like tried
[ __ ] like you don't know if your
favorite food is
Easter's if you've never had one here's
the tactical thing that I'd like to talk
about if you are not producing 100
pieces of content for Facebook Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube podcast every single
day you are leaving the greatest
opportunity in the world on the table
100 100
that's a fuckload
everything I just said sounds hard as
[ __ ] tedious of [ __ ] right but here's
the secret everything great should be
hard you doing
[Applause]
thank you for having me
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
some money I give away all my best wish
for free that's why you're here guys
this dinner and this talk are not ROI
positive for me just not could be
Garrett sailing that definitely isn't
[Laughter]
correct right correct and the best part
is when you provide value with no
expectation when they asked me they're
like hey we want to do a dinner series
I'm like cool I'm like let's do it cuz I
want the content the money is great I'm
very that is a lot of money but like the
my rev share of it is not what's driving
me to be here I'd rather go garage sale
I want the content the rock will tell
you I get more excited about buying a
stuffed animal for a dollar that's 20 on
ebay then closing a five million dollar
deal what I'm really good at is this
like it comes natural to me I don't look
at yesterday at all which is what
everybody does I really care about today
and I'm very good intuitively about
tomorrow
my religionists today my disrespect is
for yesterday my curiosity is about
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]